どういう風にして中国語を勉強したのか
うーん
ブーンん
ん
ブー
今日は[ __ ]化していくは分です今日はねー
私はどういう風にして中国語を勉強したのかそれについて話ししたいと思います
ロックの日の好きであればぜひ登録してください
金のところもキックすればあの子ら政務を届けます
そしてまあ僕と一緒にりん来てね言葉を勉強しましょう
それじゃ中国語それはねー
全968年ですから
もう50年以上前ですけれども
カナダの庶務部に入って
その通りは体はねぇ中5中国人民共和国を承認する外交官を結ぶ
時期だったそのために政府が中国語のできる人吸わせないといけないと
というようなことで
私が選ばれました
それで香港おいての中国語べきしました
あの
日本人にとってはですね中国語の語彙
いわゆる単語たくさんすぐにしてるわけでしょ
管理もしてる
ハソは違うとかね構造その頃が違うけれども合意においてはですねボキャビルにおいて
は非常に有利なんですよ
その欧米人に比べて
だからんん僕にとってはまあその東アジアの文化も違うし
歴史も違うしもちろん感じも枚ない子だから
そんなやぁ
いい国的な言葉を勉強できるがという
やはり疑問は
まあ疑問はなかったです
わかる人はスティーブはできないかもしれないですね僕はぶー問題ないと
すでにフランス号はねある程度ビュー上に華水ハネセフ話せるようになったということ
で自信があったんですよ
しかしその当時の
その勉強の条件は今の条件と全然違うんですよ
いいですね今はもう
インターネット rcm p 3プレイヤーもす
いろんなあのは私たちの人気でその使っているいろんな技術いろんな機能
その際線の辞書ん
その知らない看護も即
調べたり保存したりあとレビューしたり
その
いろいろ木曜設けて実際にどれくらいの言葉を勉強ある単語を勉強したのかとか
すべてそういう環境がですね
エアリーワンねプリウスとかああいう樹とか
何もなかったんですよ
その当時はその鉄壁こうだというのはこんなでかいやつですよね
そのもちろん思って箱がないんですよね
そのそこで座って聴くしかない
っっそしてまあ位中国語
もう読むときにですね
あの11辞書に調べないといけない
そんな際宣伝すぐ調べたりするようなことはもう無理ですよねはなかったんですよね
で中国まあこれ日本人はそれに慣れているけれども欧米時に撮ったですね
一つの漢字はねその子のあるですよ
フォークス英語で言いますねそれを数えて調べ辞書で調べたら
事情も姫たらもうすぐ忘れますよね
だから
のがまずこの住所使わない
あの
そういう子様の昇格れっ村にですね
合意表が付いてるような本
そこをしそれしか読まないだから
米みたぁさんそういう方がはですよ僕は香港でパッ北京語を勉強したはいいんですよ
だから周りはパイ北京語じゃないんですね周りはもう
カンドン号今は香港でねピングを話せる人も結構多いんですけれども
50年前はほとんどいなかったんですよねだから全部自分で読んだり聞いたりするしか
ないんですよ周りの
そういう言語の環境がないいなかったんですよ
まあ僕は日本に住んでた時のように
誰とでも話できるわけですよね日本にするから日本語を勉強すると
しかし香港はそうじゃなかったんですよ第そういう本
あるいはいろんなその
内容を聞いたりするしかなかったんですよ
出前日3時間
先生とは1いっぱい家で猛レッスンもあったんですよ
だけども主に毎日6時間7時間も聞いたり読んだり書いたりするようなことをしたわけ
ですよ
出始めにあの始め2ヶ月間ですねかじなしその
比較的簡単な会話
あの当時僕にとって非常に側道の半早い会話聞いて
そしてそのピーン4 day ある程度ある程度との中国語に関して北京語に関して
んな
脳が少し慣れてきたわけですよねその後
管理を始めたわけです
漢字はですねそのこれは日本人には別に問題じゃないけれども我々にとってあの訪米時
にとっては11勉強しないといけない
11回たり聞いたり読んだり
忘れたりもう一度勉強したりそれが最初の扇蔵で一番苦しかっ
たんですけれどもまぁあとはだんだんといろんな新しいないを読んで
やはりこの感じをさは分かるようになったんですよ
そして在所に選んだ面白い本はですね
pro 版英語デイトレディース中旬 chinese 買う2
あの[ __ ]55 a じゃーん
中国本かー
20その話っていうか
それ以来中国の毛な歴史について
その現代よは20世紀の歴史までのいろんなないようですね
簡単な厨房でも選んだ理由ですよだから内容が面白い
だから目標はその中国に感謝
して勉強したいから中国が面白い
古い文化もそうだし20世紀の女あの古い文化がその西洋の文化にぶつかって技術的に
西洋の文化の方が優れてた
水性活字もた高かったけれども中国というのはもう
ね30004000年の歴史もある文化もある
技術もある非常にプライド高い文化とその西洋の文化とぶつかってじゃあどういう風に
するか
ちょの西洋の僕の中何をその
我々も適用するか何を協議する
我々の僕は何が残るかその辺がね色んなその
人たちのよあのインターネットはっていうかへ
10分ずか考えたり
非常に面白かったんですよだからその情報を会う日じゃ
この後はですねこういうこれまた英語ですけれども
n ビリー billy jean チャーにそれもやはり同じように本物の文書
これは
中国のその
[音楽]
あれですよあの
実際の神乳人物とかサッカーとかそういう人たちの書いたもの
それを読んで少しずつ
この
感じののわかる感じの数が増えたり
そして文法的な説明はできるだけ避けて
まあ一つは中国号の文化がぼけてかあろう
文法文法ですよねクラブ割と簡単ですよ
しかしそれでも
言葉を教える本屋へ選手たちができないそれが複雑にするんですよ
それは僕は1社もしして
パターンですよ
英語ではこういうふうに言います中国語ではこういうふうに言います
そのパターンパターンごとにですねその
いわゆる
吸収してですね
少しずつ中国語に慣れてきたわけですよ
それから
残念ながらあの当時はですね色んな定期人僕はですね
教会障害ですねその
いわゆるお塩がなかったんですだけども僕はその中国語でユーシアン車
これがそのやはり
がどういますかねえ
まあ英語で言うコメディアンがねぇ
お互いにいろんな話するその中国語のトーンですねまぁまぁまぁ
我と so バスわけですよああいう9ミリあの人たちがだからその豚ずになれるには
ですね非常に便利なんですよねこういう cd わねそれは50年前に買ったもんじゃ
ないんです
よねこれはあの
まあ20年
15年前に中国いいた時に方もんですけれども今はその必要もない
u 10からいくらでもシェアオプション
あのー探せる
あの練気にもそのそれを導入して提起しても
レッスンになったりすることもあるわけですよね
だから周りの環境がその僕が中国語を勉強した時に比べて
もう全然良くなってるわけですよだけ
日本人が中国のその分強の影響は非常にあっ
もちろん大きいわけですよ
日本語のその合意日本語そのものの防衛が半分くらいは中国語からきてるんですよね
感じもわかる c 隣の文だし
文化的に非常に影響が深いというようなことをから見て北へ欧米人に比べて日本人日本
画ですね日本人にとってはですね条件が6優れてるわけですよだから是非その非常に
面白い
あれですよ
ゆたからねその隣の組の文化を勉強すると同時にその言葉も勉強するように
推薦しますまあそういうような非常に簡単に僕はという風にして中国語を勉強した
いくつかのポイントだけ
まあ開始したわけですよそれじゃどうもならんぶーん
ん
入った